hagamos más ejemplos de resta de
decimales digamos que queremos descubrir
cuánto es 2 menos 1.2 pausa en el vídeo
y traten de resolverlo existen muchas
maneras de abordar esto en una de estas
maneras podemos decir que esto es lo
mismo que dos menos uno menos dos
decimos esto es igual a uno y dos
decimos así que estamos restando dos
decimos ahora dos menos uno es muy fácil
de resolver dos menos uno es igual a uno
y le tenemos que restar dos decimos a
esto uno es lo mismo que diez décimos
diez décimos y si le restamos dos
decimos cuál va a ser el resultado bueno
esto es igual a ocho decimos que es lo
mismo que 0.8
una manera de ver esto es que si aún no
le estamos restando dos décimos y vemos
el 1 como 1.0 y en lugar de expresar
esto como una unidad de 0 décimos
pensamos en esto como 0 unidades y 10
décimos
y si tenemos 10 décimos y le restamos 2
decimos es más fácil pensar y decir
bueno a 10 de algo le restó 2 de algo me
quedan 8 en este caso 8 decimos bueno
también podemos visualizarlo en una
recta numérica así que déjenme dibujarla
aquí tenemos el 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 aquí
está el 1 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 y aquí
tenemos 2 y vamos a empezar en 2 y le
vamos a restar 1 y 2 decimos y una
manera de hacerlo es primero restar 1 y
luego restamos 2 decimos y esto nos da
como resultado 0.8 en la recta numérica
y otra manera de verlo el objetivo es
revisar muchas estrategias para que
puedan decidir cuál les gusta más y que
se den cuenta de que todas las
estrategias nos llevan al mismo
resultado si están pensando en esto de
manera razonable podrían preguntarse
cuál es la diferencia entre 2 y 1.2
entonces 1.2 se encuentra aquí en la
recta numérica y ahora cuánto es la
diferencia entre 2 y 1 y 2 decimos
otra forma de verlo es preguntarnos
cuántos décimos le tenemos que sumar a
uno y dos décimos para llegar a dos
buenos y tenemos 1.2 tenemos que sumarle
ocho décimos para llegar al siguiente
entero así que tenemos que sumar ocho
décimos
tenemos que sumar 0.8 entonces la
diferencia entre 2 y 1.2 la diferencia
entre 2 y 1.2 es igual a 0.8 hagamos más
ejemplos para practicar un poco digamos
que queremos calcular cuánto es 3.8
menos 1.5 pausa del vídeo y traten de
resolverlo
bueno como lo hice antes podemos ver
esto como tres menos uno estamos
restando las unidades más ocho decimos
menos cinco decimos
fíjense que tenemos tres y ocho décimos
- 1 y 5 decimos
y ahora lo podemos calcular ok tres
menos uno es igual a dos y luego ocho
decimos menos cinco decimos bueno esto
es igual a tres décimos y todo esto va a
ser igual a dos y tres decimos que
podemos escribir como 2.3 esta fue
realmente fácil
hagamos un ejemplo un poco más difícil
digamos que queremos calcular cuatro y
cinco décimos o 4.5 menos dos y ocho
décimos o 2.8 pausa en el vídeo y traten
de resolverlo tal vez quieran hacer lo
mismo que hicimos antes probablemente
digan ok bueno esto es lo mismo
resolvamos primero las unidades esto es
4 - 2
más cinco décimos
- ocho décimos
4 y 5 decimos menos 2 y 8 decimos esto
es exactamente lo que tenemos aquí
entonces dirán muy bien
4 - 2 es igual a 2 pero luego tenemos
cinco décimos y le tenemos que restar
ocho décimos hay muchas formas de
abordar esto probablemente estés
pensando cómo le voy a restar ocho
décimos a cinco décimos y tenemos muchas
estrategias en las que podemos pensar
para hacer esto podríamos decir cómo
puedo conseguir algunos décimos más aquí
tengo cinco décimos
y le tengo que restar 8 décimos
podría tener más decimos aquí lo mejor
que se me ocurre para resolver esto es
descomponer estas unidades porque una
unidad es igual a 10 decimos así que
podemos ver el 2 como uno más uno y este
uno lo podemos ver como diez décimos y
si vemos el dos como uno y diez décimos
podemos entonces sumarlos a estos cuánto
es diez décimos más cinco décimos
- ocho décimos
cuál es el resultado bueno esto es muy
sencillo 10 décimos más cinco décimos
es igual a 15 décimos
y si tenemos 15 décimos y le quitamos
ocho décimos nos van a quedar siete
décimos
así que esto es igual a 17 decimos si
resolvemos todo esto nos va a dar como
resultado 7 decimos y lo puedo escribir
como 0.7 así que el resultado es 1 y 7
decimos
ahora hay otra estrategia que podemos
usar aquí y es lo que yo hago en mi
cabeza
escribo esto como 4.5 menos 2.5 menos
0.3
4 y 5 decimos menos 2 y 5 decimos menos
tres decimos y porque lo escribo de esta
manera porque esto es muy fácil de
resolver y luego nada más tendré que
restar tres décimos si tengo cinco
décimos y le quito 5 decimos esto se van
a ir y solo me va a quedar 4 menos 2 que
es igual a 2 y solo le tengo que restar
3 decimos 0.3 y esta es una manera fácil
de hacerlo en la mente cuanto es dos
menos tres décimos bueno pueden
visualizar una recta numérica en sus
cabezas y esto va a ser igual a uno y
siete décimos y si les parece extraño
que lo haya resuelto tan rápido piensen
en esto esto es lo mismo que uno más uno
menos 0.3 y este uno de aquí es igual a
diez décimos
y diez décimos menos tres décimos es
igual a siete décimos
y el resultado es 1 y 7 decimos que es
lo que obtuvimos anteriormente el punto
aquí es que se den cuenta de que hay
muchas estrategias para restar decimales
algunas pueden ser automáticas pero es
realmente bueno pensar en lo que está
pasando en su mente y algunas
estrategias son más fáciles en su mente
que en papel